[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans point
de vue merci d'être au rendez vous pour
notre échanges quotidiens sur les sujets
d'actualité
nous recevons ce soir patrick peloux
bonsoir docteur vous êtes médecin
urgentiste à l'hôpital necker et au samu
de paris
votre dernier livre urgence de vivre est
un recueil de chroniques
c'est par où il ya quelques jours aux
éditions du cherche midi et comme je les
lui je peux dire que c'est un livre très
très humain merci beaucoup à votre image
bonsoir ivan rioufol vous êtes
journaliste essayiste éditorialiste au
figaro est votre dernier livre qui est
aussi je crois un recueil de vos
chroniques
le réveil des somnambules a été publié
aux éditions de l'artilleur il ya deux
mois c'est ça oui peut-être un peu plus
un peu d'être un petit peu plus avec le
co vide effectivement le calendrier
éditorial est un peu bousculé je vous
propose de profiter de la présence d'un
éminent médecin parmi nous pour se
focaliser sur deux points différents de
l'actualité épidémique
on va commencer par parler des
restaurateurs les patrons de restaurants
mais aussi d'hôtel de discothèques ont
lancé une journée de revendications
c'était aujourd'hui avec des
manifestations avec des prises de
paroles pour évidemment protester contre
la fermeture de leur établissement
écoutez philippe etchebest le chef star
de l'émission top chef
il était tout à l'heure sur l'esplanade
des invalides
ce rassemblement est il une colère
légitime et nous voyons que la
mobilisation est énorme
notre profession doit être enfin reconnu
comme un secteur essentiel de l'économie
du pays et de l'art de vivre à la
française
nous sommes réunis aujourd'hui pour dire
au gouvernement laissez nous travailler
nous voyons bien qu'il n'y a pas de
logique dans les décisions prises au fil
des semaines et nous subissons les joies
du trec'h et les décisions
voilà laissez nous travailler dit
philippe etchebest de le problème c'est
que la réouverture n'est pas pour tout
de suite la réouverture des restaurants
et des hôtels on avait parlé du 20
janvier
mais même cette échéance là n'est pas
gagné écoutez bruno le maire il était ce
matin chez nos confrères de france info
je recevrai à nouveau les restaurateurs
dans les semaines qui viennent je vais
avec eux quels sont les accompagnements
complémentaires qui sont nécessaires
pour eux comment est ce qu ils peuvent
redémarrer
comment est-ce qu'on peut les
accompagner aussi sur le long terme
parce que les restaurateurs aujourd'hui
vidée vivent des moments qui sont
terribles donc nous allons continuer à
les accompagner mais vous dira le 20
janvier c'est fini on rouvre il n'y a
pas de difficultés ce serait prendre un
risque excessif de dire cela ivan
rioufol philippe etchebest parle d'
absence de logique de choix arbitraire
est ce que vous êtes aussi sévère oui je
pense que le seuil de tolérance est
atteint aujourd'hui il ya une
incompréhension d'une partie de
l'opinion sur cette rigidité de l'ordre
sanitaire qui s'impose maintenant depuis
huit mois et surtout j'ai lu ce matin
dans les échos
une étude qui me paraît épouvantablement
inquiétant qu'il révèle avec sondage
sofres à l'appui qu'un français sur cinq
pense aujourd'hui au suicide vous avez
29 % des jeunes de moins de 25 ans qui
ont au joueur qui sont sujets à de
telles pensées morbides et donc on
s'aperçoit que au prétexte de sauver des
vies et naturellement tout le monde a
applaudi moi le premier a sauvé des vies
nous sommes en train d'en mettre en
péril encore bien davantage donc la
question est de savoir si aujourd'hui ne
faut pas s'arrêter pour essayer de
préserver ceux qui sont qui menace
aujourd'hui de se tuer je ne pourrais
pas en parler que ceux ci mais également
de parler de ceux qui sont en détresse
psychologique en parlant des
restaurateurs et du sort que l'on
réservé à la culture naturellement qui
est un sort épouvantable qui n'est pas
digne d'une démocratie en tout cas la
démocratie française
patrick peloux je voyais opiné du chef
mais en même temps vous le fait de
sauver des vies vous le voyez
quotidiennement donc c'est utile de
faire ça oui mais
je reviens sur ce que média fort
justement dire qu'on va sauver des vies
n'est pas un passe droit sur justement
le droit de l'époque la démocratie et la
liberté de parole et de juger c'est à
dire que quelqu'un qui n'est pas médecin
et a fortiori qui n'est pas professeur a
tout à fait le droit d'avoir une pensée
et une expression par rapport à la
situation c'est pour ça que ce qui
oppose le discours de certains médecins
à ce qui vient d'être dit pareil chez ps
se trompe parce que c'est la liberté
d'expression en examen ça parce que il
ya beaucoup de vos confrères et sur les
plateaux de télévision quand on a un
discours critique disons venez avec moi
aux urgences ou en réanimation et et
vous verrez we say say say c'est je
souffre tu comprends pas ma souffrance
je vais te couper la jambe comme ça tu
vas souffrir
elle est belle la logique c'est pas du
tout comme ça qu'il faut voir les choses
nous avons une véritable nouvelle
maladie qui est sur terre donc déjà il
ya un problème de vocabulaire quand on a
dit qu'il y avait une épidémie si vous
dites épidémie vous dites parenthèse en
fait la parenthèse est très longue
donc en fait je pense que là il faut
vraiment se dire qu'il y a
bénéfice/risque à avoir ce que vous
dites est très juste nous ça fait à peu
près et je le dis dans les médias depuis
à peu près trois semaines qui a une
augmentation de la souffrance que les
suicides augmentent
nous avons des alertes sanitaires de la
pédopsychiatrie de la psychiatrie des
ados c'est vraiment un problème très
grave
d'accord augmentation de 20% de
consommation des anxiolytiques des anxio
dépressifs et des ongles et des
antidépresseurs
donc c'est vraiment une situation très
très grave c'est pour ça que il faut
repenser à ce qu'avait dit edouard
philippe
en avril quand tu avais dit attention il
ya l'écroulement de la france
et là on joue avec de la dynamite parce
que en fait c'est bien beau ce qu'ils
disent est tout à fait juste on laisse
faire des rassemblements de foules très
important notamment dans les grands que
dans les commerces et c'est tant mieux
parce que il faut fêter noël etc puis
d'un autre côté ont contraint certains
milieux sans avoir d'ailleurs de preuves
scientifiques plus importante que
d'autres
ce qu'on oublie c'est que c'est du long
terme cette crise et du long terme il
falloir vivre avec ça il faut mieux
renforcer les barrières sanitaires
discuter avec les professionnels pour
voir comment est-ce qu'on aménage mais
il faut donner de la douceur c'est pour
ça que moi j'étais pour enfin j'ai
vraiment pas compris je dois vous avouer
la fermeture des théâtres des cinémas et
du monde de la culture
j'ai pas compris les restaurants comme
vous je vais dans certains restaurants
c'est vrai qu'il y en a ils sont très
très étroit et c'est assez difficile
il y en ad'autres suis allé dans des
restaurants écouter l'hygiène et les
plus respectables et plus respecté que
dans certains services hospitaliers
d'accord donc il faut pas il faut quand
même un moment il faut se mettre ici il
faut un peu de raison garder
parce que c'est sans fin en fait vous
comprenez c'est sans fin parce qu'on
sait qu'il va y avoir une troisième
saison une 3e vague puis peut-être une
4e et c'est qui on sait pas comment le
virus donc on va vivre toute l'histoire
de l'humanité avec ça mais ça voudrait
dire que conceptuellement il ya toujours
eu des vagues et des épidémies donc on
va contraindre le pays ad vitam aeternam
mais non c'est impossible
vous en parlez avec vos confrères oh là
là ce que vous disent est ce qu'ils vous
disent mais nantes est responsable
alors si on rouvre les cinémas
partenaires guillaume il ya une chasse
aux sorcières qui a commencé dans le
monde notamment l'assistance publique ou
en fait si vous dites
et si vous parlez aux il ya des
collègues ont révélé notamment des
dysfonctionnements et c'est qu'ils se
retrouvent en disciplinaire au conseil
de l'ordre à dire que là ça ne rigole
plus donc ce qui si vous voulez quand je
dis ça je sais que je prends un risque
je prends un risque d'avoir l'eau propre
d'un certain nombre de grandes
personnalités enfin qui se croient
grandes personnalités de l'assistance
publique et qui ne veulent pas remettre
en cause parce que vous comprenez il ya
un certain nombre de médecins qui ont
goûté au pouvoir
et ça c'est une drogue dure ils ont
goûté au pouvoir en se disant [ __ ]
mais c'est génial on a on a la main sur
le pays
on peut contraindre la junte sanitaire
la junte sanitaires c'est pas parce
qu'une société peut pas être bâtis comme
ça voyez ça peut pas être bâtis comme ça
et là c'est trop long et là les
conséquences
ça a été dit par les cancérologues qu'on
dit on à augmenter quand on a fait une
erreur épouvantable en mars avril quand
on a dit aux gens on ne soigne plus que
coronavirus le reste vous attendez
vous mais ça c'est pas possible en fait
voyez faut revenir en arrière c'est très
important ce que vous dites là parce que
ce n'est pas ce que j'entends d'habitude
de la part des médecins lorsqu'il ya
quand même je constate moi une hystérie
sanitaire je constate un sanitairement
correct qui d'ailleurs en corrélation
avec le politiquement correct c'est à
dire que l'on s'est habitué à avoir une
pensée unique une pensée unique qui a
été décrété officiellement qui a été de
dire qu'il fallait par la peur
terroriser les gens et faire en sorte
que ce qu vide et est montré comme étant
un ennemi épouvantable ce qu vide est
naturellement très dangereux mais
d'abord je pense que sa létalité je ne
sais pas si vous êtes d'accord avec ce
chiffre là je vois il est de 1 pour 1000
je ne sais pas si vous avez un pour
mille c'est déjà un chiffre qu'il
faudrait qu'il faudrait tout de même
interrogé est ce que pour lutter contre
un virus qui tue un pour mille
il faut à ce point cassé l'économie
brise et brisé des vies et moi je ne le
pense pas je pense qu'il faut sortir de
cette hystérie je pense que la politique
doit refaire de la politique c'est à
dire qu'elle doit se débarrasser en tout
cas qu'elle doit s'émanciper de toute la
de tous ses conseils sa fille qui vit
dit qu'ils ne le disent c'est comme le
type qui a un marteau qui y voient des
clous partout quand vous vous demandez à
un médecin
ils voient des malades par tout
naturellement et donc vous ne pouvez pas
vous ne pouvez pas demander à la
politique de simplement de ceux de se
mettre dans les mains de ces experts il
faut maintenant qu'elle retrouve le goût
de la vie le goût du terrain
comment vivent les gens et les villes
les gens vivent d'abord dames les gens
ne sont pas fous ils n'ont pas envie de
tuer leur grand-mère ou l'ordre en perd
ils ont bien compris qu'elles étaient
les gestes barrière mais je pense qu'il
faut d'abord peut-être apprendre d'abord
à soigner cette maladie plutôt que de
vouloir à tout prix s'en préserver
peut-être se soignent hôtel il
semblerait qu'il y avait des processus
médicaux qui était interdit en france
comme lille roxy chloroquine kir qui a
été à nouveau autorisée en italie
d'ailleurs je crois et en espagne
récemment se poser ces questions là et
essayer de sortir en effet de ce que
j'ai appelé moi à d'un despotisme
sanitaire une dictature sanitaire dans
la mesure où elle a mis en cause
beaucoup de nos propres libertés
le problème c'est que en fait si le
gouvernement n'avait rien fait et s'il
avait laissé filer un peu si vous voulez
masse que maintenant c'est un concept le
tropisme ainsi si d'un coup on avait
fait comme trump
on aurait eu probablement deux à trois
fois plus de morts et on aurait accusé
les autorités de pas l'avoir fait donc
entre les deux en fait si vous voulez
c'est pas
hop je pense qu'on peut trouver quelque
chose qui permettent à la société de
redémarrer dans un souci vraiment
sanitaire parce que vous savez que
salutaire c'est pas que la médecine
c'est le psychologie le psyché donc le
psyché collectif et c'est le social le
social le social eh ben c'est
merveilleux parce que le social il
commence le matin quand
ok je vais faire un gars mais je vais
acheter mon journal je vais voir le
canadien a bien en bas non mes films
c'est vrai tu vas boire le café en bas
on regarde toi tes amis on aime tout ça
bon et puis après vous avez des ans des
fêtes des médecins qui sont partis en
vrille quand il y en a un qui a dit à
noël papy mamie à la cuisine mais là la
ccsa c'est fou et pourtant c'est
quelqu'un d'estimables mai mais il
déborde
il déborde et ce qu'il faut voir la sexy
en fait on trouve pas quelque chose et
un compromis une digue mais je suis sûr
qu'on peut trouver quelque chose qui
voyait on a trouvé la solution en disant
aux gens on les transporte en train bon
on les transporte en train ont fait pas
un siège sur deux les gens obéissent
j'ai pris le train plusieurs fois les
gens obéissent c'est incroyable on
pensait que les français transgressait
toutes les directives c'est faux les
français les français respectent le port
du masque
je le vois chez vous les bars et les
gestes barrières ont été ses respectés
par tous bon on n'a pas arrêté les
trains
on n'a pas arrêté les trains bon donc du
coup il ya il ya on a l'impression qu'on
tape sur tout ce qui est en fait sur le
lien le lien social mais c'est qu'on
mette en place des directives sanitaires
pour les restaurants les bars etc
mais voilà de manière à enlever cette
étreinte voyez alors ils ont d'accord je
comprends qu'ils disent noël on laisse
faire jour de l'an au quai jour de lens
ça serait trop compliqué donc il y
aurait des fêtes et cédera donc je
comprends le truc
voilà mais pour le reste du temps moi je
je fais partie de ceux et je comprends
mais je le soigne tous les jours des
gens atteints du corps aux navires je
peux vous dire qu'on a fait des progrès
considérables sur le léman
ce qu'on ne fait rien d'autre là c'est
d'éviter d'aggraver la crise de
l'hôpital parce que le fond de cette ce
problème
c'est la crise de l'hôpital et si on
n'avait pas fermé autant de lits de
réanimation médicale et si le
gouvernement l'a autorisé la réouverture
de réanimation médicale n'y a pas de
sujet une compagnie nos internautes sont
globalement d'accord avec vous - le sort
réservé aux restaurateurs dans la crise
du coc vide 19 et il injuste vous
répondez oui à 70%
vous qui réagissent et sur twitter en
direct en même temps que vous écoutez
l'émission quelques commentaires celui
d'annie sur youtube j'ai l'impression
que nos politiques ne se rendent pas
compte de ce que ces fermes bio implique
pour les gens des vies entières sont
brisés il faut arrêter ça christophe
nous rappelle sur figaro live qui n'a
pas que les restaurateurs que tout le
secteur de l'événementiel est aussi à
l'arrêt et puis ici le diable sur
youtube c'est honteux ce que l'on fait
aux restaurateurs certains ont investi
pour s'équiper pour respecter les
mesures sanitaires et voilà comment on
les remercie je le disais il ya aussi
les patrons de discothèques qui
manifestaient aujourd'hui ils vont pour
le 31 décembre
sachant que pour le coup en boîte de
nuit même si j'y vais pas tous les jours
mes souvenirs sont que me disent qu'on
était assez serré est-ce que là vous
auriez autorisé ça aussi au nom de cette
liberté qui vous est cher n'ont
peut-être pas on n'est pas obligé non
plus de provoquer les choses à ce point
mais en tout cas peut-être d'où je pense
que ce couvre-feu à 20 heures et tout de
même très humiliant 13 enfants disant
alors sur cette question précise de la
discothèque je ne veux pas me prononcer
parce que je ne veux pas non plus faire
le faire le malin il est sans doute on
peut reconstituer des dés je crois que
mon appel salades et des clusters et
kloster exact mais moi ce qui me ce qui
me ce qui me choque c'est que l'on est
en train d'analyser une société
précisément du nom contacter en tout on
voulait vivre ensemble en fait
maintenant on est sommée précisément
d'avoir peur de son voisin on n'ose même
plus serré la main on n'ose plus à peine
se taper sur l'épaule et donc on voit
bien que cette cette société là est une
société qui devient invivable et moi
j'aimerais que dans le débat public
aujourd'hui se pose la question de
savoir comment nous allons sortir de là
urgemment se dire que je ne peux pas je
ne conçois pas qu'à partir de janvier
s'il ya une autre vague qui viennent
l'on recommence avec ses confinement
cela me paraîtrait une mortelle donc il
va falloir accepter que l'on prenne des
risques voilà c'est ce mot est ce ce mot
épouvantable que personne n'ose
prononcer singulièrement pas les hommes
politiques qui se retranche derrière
leur sécurité juridique
mais il va falloir que les français je
pense en tout cas moi je serais prêt à
les accepter je les accepte déjà
je pense que beaucoup de français
pensent comme moi car ils voient bien
que et on va pas revenir sur ce que j'ai
dit au départ cette politique sanitaire
là qui au prétexte d'être humaniste est
en train de créer un monde inhumain mais
franchement inhumain et un monde
invivable de mon point de vue invivable
alors je précise que même si vous pouvez
apparaître messieurs l'un à côté de
l'autre sur l'écran sur le plateau vous
êtes existe ce qui est intéressant c'est
que l'état d'esprit divan et les plutôt
minoritaires dans les sondages chez les
français patrick peloux la majorité des
gens disent mais oui le confinement
c'est bien il faut être
il faut être raisonnable il faut être
prudent mais parce que nous avons un
pays qui est très sensible nous avons
appliqué très sensible dans un pays qui
aient peur je crois hélas qu'il aime
avoir peur mais ça c'est autre chose
mais du coup d'avoir comme ça depuis ça
fait quand même neuf mois que ça tourne
comme ça comme comme une machine à laver
un donc d'un coup en effet j'ai des amis
qui d'un coup veulent aller voir leurs
parents leur part leur dise non non non
vous ne venez pas ça met tout le monde
dans une situation de rupture
sentimentale et de fractures affective
assez importante
eh bien eh bien c'est un certain temps
vous parliez des discothèques
c'est important de la danse en fait je
suis un très mauvais danseur mais je
crois que c'est vraiment très important
et il n'y a pas de raison qu'on ne
trouve pas une solution il faut trouver
des solutions met les professionnels
autour de la table et dire bon bah voilà
écouter votre discothèque elle contient
d'abord combien de personnes au maximum
on réduit la joue et on recommence à
faire quelque chose parce que là si vous
voulez on ne sait pas on danse pas un
mètre cinquante les uns des autres et
pourquoi pas mais mais mais pourquoi pas
mais pourquoi pas mais si si c'est
possible pourquoi pas le fpi s'il ya des
slows bas il ya des masques enfin on
peut trouver des solutions moi je pense
qu'il faut trouver des solutions pour
relancer le système pour la salle vous
savez on parle de de la restauration
parce que nous sommes le pays de
rabelais parce que quelque part c'est la
restauration la gourmandise céphalique
c'est quelque chose qui nous permet de
vivre c'est quelque chose d'important
là on est malheureux on est on est le
pays où d'un coup
on nous dit vous mangez plus vous vous
amusez plus vous n'allez plus au théâtre
vous n'allez plus à la culture et il ya
une usure et là le pire parce que cette
fête est importante les fêtes de fin
d'année sont importantes
contrairement à ce qu'on dit c'est pas
c'est pas la ripaille lancé la réunion
des familles c'est la réunion des
familles et bien là on leur a dit
attention ça se trouve vous vous
réunissez pas mais je vous assure le
moral des gens le mort a déjà un mot de
conclusion sur ses champions il manque
dans ce débat la parole des
intellectuels la parole des philosophes
la parole des religieux aussi pourquoi
pas pour essayer de mettre en
perspective une vie nue parce que là on
nous aurons nous sommes de respecter la
vie nue c'est bien une vie nue une vie
sans rien une vie longue mais mais vide
n'a aucun intérêt tandis qu'une vie
courte mais rempli peut avoir de
l'intérêt est là je ne comprends pas que
les philosophes qui ne soit pas rentrer
la mère bernard henri lévy lui l'a fait
on en sort avant cité de me bernard
henri lévy et soissons ville mais
simplement pour l'heure mais quelle
fausse elle aussi a fait a fait des
beaux textes bon d'accord 3 3 mais enfin
convenez avec moi tout de même parce que
d'un sujet existant à celle ci aurait
mérité non seulement que l'on
s'interroge sur la place de la culture 9
mai de rappeler que la culture est quand
même notre notre adn que la led avec ce
sujet le philosophe d'avoir c'est
d'avoir su peu d'avoir interdit la
lecture d'avoir interdit la bouffe
également la boue fait partie également
de notre culture bien entendu je ne
critique pas du tout cela c'est d'avoir
terni le théâtre cinéma alors que l'on
veut que l'on que l'on promeut les
grandes surfaces les les libres mais
l'élément que chez glénat associer tout
à fait j'avais ne soit n'ya que des gens
qui ont le moral ne soigne bien des gens
qui ont un espoir là moi et je suis
médecin je pèse mes mots j'ai soigner
des malades très grave du grenat virus
il y en a qui sont morts il ya eu des
histoires absolument affreux je suis
tout à fait d'accord on les soigne
encore je ne veux pas que l'épidémie se
redémarre mais ce qui est évident c'est
que là vous avez un bénéfice risque qui
est en défaveur et will continuer comme
ça quand d'un coup vous avez des malades
qui abandonnent tous les soins en se
disant si je vais à l'hôpital je vais
être malade dont je reste chez moi
et qu'après ils vous appellent avec les
aggravations tout leur maladie c'est
vraiment un c'est fou vous savez
personne en parle actuellement
vous avez toute la chirurgie publique
qui part dans le privé parce que on
n'opère plus parce qu'on a
programmé pour faire que les réanimation
chirurgicale qui font généralement le
pré et post opératoire se consacre aux
coronavirus très bien et ces bilans les
chirurgiens qui n'ont pas opéré dans le
public pendant à peu près deux mois
là ça a recommencé et bien les cliniques
privées leur ont dit écoutez venez nous
va tu vas travailler ensemble et c'est
donc vous avez un modification de
l'hôpital public est très inquiétante
on nous écoute pas on a des programmes
et tous les malades programmables mais
ça a vraiment vraiment des conséquences
à ce qu'on dit et cette fabrique du
stress me contredire cette famille du ce
est affaibli les eaux propres défenses
immunitaires donc c'est une aberration
et que désormais peur à ce point des
gens et bien 100% les guérir et on ne
guérit pas mais l'iran et si vous voyez
alors la belgique n'est pas comparable à
la france parce que la ccc vraiment les
conséquences de l'épidémie
c'est le pays le plus touché mais vous
avez eu quand même ce mouvement en
belgique où ils ont dit non mais il ya
une jeune coiffeuse qui venait d'ouvrir
son entreprise qui s'est suicidé qui
avait 24 ans d'accord parce qu'elles ont
le lis c'est fermé vous pourrez pu
rouvrir
c'est fini elle a vu c'est les dettes
mais on sait pas en fait c'est pas une
promesse c'est vraiment c'est là où on a
besoin je suis complètement d'accord
avec vous on a besoin de philosophie on
a besoin de sens politique et la classe
politique s'abrite derrière des experts
ce qui avait fait dire à delfraissy
d'ailleurs la france pourrait être gérée
que par des experts mais on passe
complètement fou merci alors il faut
quand même préciser que pour ce qui est
de l'accompagnement économique
il ya certes auprès d'un an dro prix
d'un endettement peut-être inquiétant
mais il ya beaucoup de choses qui sont
faites quand même par lui et le monde du
spectacle est protégé par les a cédées
dès la descente acteurs de terrain temps
si nous sommes le seul lieu au monde à
l'avoir
là vous avez la directrice d'un théâtre
en angleterre cadic un comédien sur deux
à londres et est devenu sdf bon donc non
il ya ces parapluies mais c'est pas
rappelés ne sont plus suffisants il ya
un autre point que je voudrais aborder
mais pas avant d'avoir salué chardons
bleus qui le dit qu'il est d'accord avec
ivan rioufol
ils pensent qu'on s'achemine vers une
sorte de dictature
en tout cas qui ait des tentations tel
de la part de certains ministres il ya
un autre point dans le traitement de
l'épidémie c'est le dépistage au havre
et à charleville mézières s'ouvre
aujourd'hui des campagnes de dépistage
massif généralisé s'il ya des points de
tests qui sont ouverts un peu partout ça
n'est pas obligatoire mais c est
fortement conseillé est ce que c'est une
bonne idée les tests et les tests
systématiser baccout et je vous propose
d'écouter olivier ferrand mais écoutez
le bio parce que c'est pas forcément
très cohérent vous allez me dire ce que
vous en pensez
vers en numéro 1 ça se passe le 10
décembre dernier le ministre de la santé
donne une conférence de presse vous êtes
un certain nombre de français à vous
poser la question de savoir si vous
devez vous faire tester avant de vous
rendre dans votre famille à l'occasion
des fêtes de noël
quand je dis nombreux c'est que vous
êtes potentiellement très nombreux et je
vais y venir
ça peut paraître sur le papier une bonne
idée ce que je voudrais vous dire c'est
d'abord il ya un risque de surprotection
surtout quand on n'est pas symptomatique
il ya un risque que le test soit négatif
alors qu'on ne soit pas encore
suffisamment contagieux pour pouvoir
transmettre le virus autour de soi
le test c'est pas une bonne idée sauf
que ça c'était il ya quatre jours
écoutez le même olivier ferrand
aujourd'hui au havre aux côtés d'edouard
philippe hesnault dit c'est qu'il
ressemble quand même
au contraire nous renforçons ainsi notre
stratégie tester alerté protégé par le
dépistage en population à symptomatique
d'un certain nombre d'habitants de
manière à pouvoir dépister des personnes
qui sont peut-être porteuses du virus
sans jusqu'ici le savoir bon patrick
pelloux c'est compliqué de gérer cette
cette pandémie
c'est quelque chose d'inédit n'empêche
que là quand même c'est pas très
cohérent qui a ravi je sais pas ce qui
est le plus compliqué gérer l'épidémie
et la science ou le discours politique
c'est je sais pas lequel des deux est le
plus compliqué
là c'est pas compréhensible en fait
surtout pour les françaises et français
qui sont très attentifs 1 vous avez vu
les records incroyables quand le
président de la république s'exprime
castex exprime tout le monde écoute les
cotes dans qui la région verront quand
il dit il faut se tester le plus
possible at il dit nous vous tenons
quand il faut se tester écoutez il faut
il faut être cohérent on a dit aux
françaises et aux français en février
mars
or on n'a pas les tests c'est une
catastrophe après on leur a dit c'est
bon on a les tests il faut vous testez
vous avez vu les que les gens ils on va
on va se tester hop ils y sont allés ils
sont sortis de là on a les tests on a la
possibilité de les faire référence à
l'hiver très rapidement etc etc
moi je dis si vous voulez vous faire
tester vous vous faites testé en plus de
ça je vais vous dire c'est la liberté de
chacun
il n'y a pas de raison qui est une
oppression médicales systématiques ils
les gens vont se faire tester ils
veulent être sûrs et en effet il ya une
logique les gens les gens sont pas si
bête que ça
ils disent on va aller voir un lien
rassemblement familial bas tout le monde
se teste ça fait une garantie de plus
c'est pas une certitude ce qu'a voulu
dire ministre c'est que des fois on fait
les tests et puis vous parlez le le truc
passe à côté où il ya une il ya trop peu
de virus et mais en fait c'est très
faible
vous avez vous avez une barre ya de plus
mais il faut qu'ils arrêtent de jouer au
va et vient sans arrêt parce qu'on s'y
perd en fait moi je m'étonne que ce ver
en soit encore ministre de la santé je
entendu le monsieur véran de dia neuf
mois qui nous dira que les frontières ne
servait à rien quand il fallait les
fermes et que les masques ne servait à
rien quand nous n'en avions pas que les
tests aujourd'hui ne servent à rien mais
servent quand même dire quelque chose je
l' ai vu également interdire le
protocole de draw qui est sa bête noire
visiblement qui pouvaient sensiblement
pour probablement sauvé des vies
également donc il je pense qu'il a une
responsabilité dans de cet homme
politique anxiogène est très autoritaire
qu'il a lui-même établie auprès des
auprès des citoyens français et sans
contre-pouvoir donc je pose la question
de savoir je pose la vision de sa
compétence politique pardon d'être aussi
brutale et je trouve que son état encore
un exemple de ce tout à l'heure pour
l'instant avec cette contradiction
manifeste dans une dans un propos qui me
semble être un propos incohérents
comment voulez vous que les français
aient confiance aujourd'hui dans la
parole publique
avec de tels de telles balivernes
d'hôtel de telle ou de telle manière de
vouloir se d'une journée à l'autre je
suis complètement d'accord mais ça
rejoint le discours d'un certain nombre
de professeurs de médecine qui disent
tout et le contraire dans les médias
notamment avec les vaccins
je sais pas si vous avez vu bien sûr au
dernier set a compressé et quelque part
c'est là où vous vous dites mais
finalement il ya peut-être un système
qu'on a laissé évoluer comme ça sans le
contrôler parce que toute façon les
médecins ils ont toujours des réseaux
long comme le bras d'accord mais il va
falloir peut-être un moment se dire on
va on va réformer ça pour mettre un peu
plus de transparence parce que souvent
vous avez des médecins qui prennent la
parole et qui sont souvent liées à
l'industrie pharmaceutique
si on leur en veux pas il respecte la
loi mais quelque part il ya quand même
quelque chose un cc voilà donc
donc il ya tout ce discours là qu'il
faut revoir et c'est vrai que derrière
vous avez des gens qui nous regardent et
des gens qui nous regardent et qui se
disent battant la caisse qu'est ce qu'on
fait et c'est oui le vaccin le vaccin il
va falloir le faire il faudra le faire
on est passé des tests au vaccin mais si
vous voulez en fait là vous avez une
c'est fou à dire mais c'est la réalité
il ya un vaccin qui arrive qui a été
testée c'est vrai que les études elles
sont arrivées comme comme ils ont voulu
vous avez quand même la food and drugs
américaine qui l'a validé vous savez
très bien qu'aux états unis si on valide
si vous faites une bêtise dans la
validation vous avez des procès à plus
savoir qu'en faire donc je pense qu'ils
ont quand même vachement vérifier le
truc
bon et puis la grandeur nature vous avez
les vaccins qui apparaissent en
angleterre et aux états unis donc nous
le temps que ça se mette en place
on aura du recul donc il faut être il
faut être apaisées sur cette notion de
vaccins on aura quelque chose mais si
vous voulez il ya un discours officiel
qui doit être homogénéiser où on soit
tous d'accord c'est pas pour avoir la
parole de du kgb
c'est pas ça c'est d'avoir une parole
qui rassure parce que les français ont
besoin d'être assurés à l'heure actuelle
et qu'on leur dise voilà ils ont besoin
de quoi c'est un peu ce que disent les
restaurateurs ils disent on a besoin
d'une ligne mais qu'on nous dise voilà
c'est le temps c'est le temps on est on
sera prêt le temps etc
il sait là et c'est là où je vous dis il
faut quelque part avoir de la douceur
avec le pays france 3 ce pardon je vais
vous poser l'appareil sur cela donne
aussi à nos internautes qui vous suivent
avec beaucoup d'attention notamment
françois sur lefigaro.fr qui pensent
comme vous qu'on subit une véritable
cacophonie de la part de la communauté
scientifique comment s'y retrouver
s'interroge-t-il épi pose une autre
question elle est devenu presque
classique sur les plateaux de télévision
mais mais après tout pourquoi pas
françois donc sur lefigaro.fr demande à
nos invités vous ferez vous vacciner
ils vont je n'ai rien contre je n'ai pas
de religion contre le vaccin je serai
prudent parce que je vois bien malgré
tout qu'il y à des incertitudes donc
j'attendrai de voir si vous me permettez
je serai pas le premier à me faire
vacciner ce que je voulais voir ce juste
une petite réflexion si avant de se
quitter je trouve que il y a une si on
devait tirer un bilan positif malgré
tout de cette crise sanitaire c'est
qu'elles révèlent tout tous les maux de
la société c'est de se sic il va falloir
sur lequel il va falloir travailler
certes et cela révèle naturellement
l'absurdité du centralisme la
technocratie de la bureaucratie cela
révèle l'incohérence de cette hyper
président présidentielle
présidentialisation cela révèle la crise
de la démocratie où on a vu qu'il n'y
avait plus de contre-pouvoirs cela
révèle également la passivité de la
presse qui a suivi un discours sans
vouloir apporter une contradiction ou un
esprit critique et je pense que tout
ceci forme un tout il va falloir qu'elle
à l'issue de cette crise qui va être
dévastatrices elle sera dévastatrice
également d'un point de vue politique me
semble-t-il il va falloir tout
reconstruire et singulièrement éviter
qu'on colle pour que l'on évite ses
travers qui nous ont fait perdre du
temps qu'ils ont hâte à mener à un
régime trop autoritaire trop liberticide
de mon point de vue et à une apathie
générale qui m'inquiète parce qu'il
inquiète le plus aujourd'hui en effet
vous l'avez rappelé c'est que une grande
partie de l'opinion n'est pas du tout
sur mon terrain c'est à dire qu'elle est
prête à accepter la servitude et ceci
mes frais pour des jours qu'il pourrait
être plus noirs même question dr pelloux
vous faites vacciner vous très vite à
priori vous êtes à risque
votre métier je suis je pense qu'il faut
se faire vacciner mais là encore si vous
avez le temps que les vaccins arrivent
en france etc
nous aurons le recul des millions de
personnes qui auront été vaccinés en
angleterre aux états unis donc on aura
ce recul là ce recul sur donc vous
faites pas vacciner tout de suite cet
intérêt pour le moment où tu saches là
votre la compétence n'est pas disponible
il n'est pas et si je vous ai si
j'arrive demande disant tiens j'en ai un
pour vous je les rapporter 2 l'on en
attend on attendait on attend pourquoi
parce que tous les schémas de contrôle
que nous avons en france n'ont pas été
encore n'ont pas été encore fait
d'accord et ils sont je pense plus
rigoureux que ce que notamment sur les
vaccins parce qu'il plein de polémique
au cours de ces dernières années sur les
patients c'est plus rigolo faut un tout
petit peu de patiente faut pas remettre
en cause ce vaccin mais voilà on a de
toute façon un test grandeur nature
merci beaucoup à tous les deux et puis
se termine en vous donnant le résultat
de notre
petite enquête express auprès de nos
internautes faut-il rendre systématique
des opérations de dépistage
vous répondez non à 55,5 pour cent voilà
merci beaucoup merci d'avoir participé à
ce débat merci à tous et on se retrouve
demain pour une nouvelle édition de
point de vue
[Musique]